ahora que ya sabemos sacar máximos y
mínimos es hora de hacer problemas de
optimización con máximos y mínimos y
seguramente se van a preguntar hoy a sal
que es un problema de optimización pues
yo les voy a contestar un problema de
optimización es justo lo que vamos a ver
ahorita entonces en el transcurso de
este vídeo vamos a entender por qué se
llaman problemas de optimización así que
empecemos con un primer problema
supongamos que yo me quiero encontrar un
par de números tales que su producto sea
menos 16 es decir la multiplicación de
ambos me de menos 16 y además con una
siguiente restricción que la suma de
esos cuadrados sea mínimo ese va a ser
mi problema es decir yo quiero dos
números tales que al multiplicarlos me
den menos 16 pero además de toda la
pareja de números que sus productos me
da menos 16
yo voy a querer aquellos que la suma de
sus cuadrados sea la menor cantidad es
decir que la suma de su cuadrado sea
mínimo
por eso son problemas de optimización
pues bueno una vez que tenemos el
problema ahora
escribirlo en un lenguaje matemático
entonces yo quiero dos números que su
producto sea menos 16 lo voy a tomar 2
cualquiera supongamos x x porque me
tienen que dar menos 16 y yo quiero que
la suma de sus cuadrados sea mínimo es
decir ese le voy a poner a ese la suma
de los cuadrados es mi función tal que x
cuadrada más vía cuadrada sea mínimo lo
que yo quiero hacer que esta función
esto de aquí sea mínimo tras de eso voy
bien pero yo no sé cálculo de varias
variables entonces no podría derivar
esta función porque todavía no sé cómo
se derivan una función que tiene dos
variables entonces vamos a utilizar la
ecuación de restricción que cuesta una
restricción pues que x porque es igual a
menos 16 entonces si yo en esta ecuación
despejó a x o despejó ayer y la meto en
función ya voy a tener una función de
una variable vamos a hacerlo de esta
ecuación yo tengo que si x porque es
igual a menos 16 pues entonces a lleva a
ser igual a quien apuesta menos 16 y voy
a pasar del otro lado dividiendo la x
muy bien hasta aquí vamos perfecto y si
ya tengo aquí entonces yo puedo
sustituir esta y en mi función s es
decir s es igual a x cuadrada más
cuadrada pero quien es cuadrada pues es
elevado al cuadrado es decir más a 256
que es el cuadrado 16 y x cuadrada que
es el cuadrado de x muy bien ya tenemos
mi función s que es igual a x cuadrada
más 256 entre x cuadrada y ya ven s ya
solamente depende de una variable de x
por lo tanto yo ya puede utilizar lo que
hemos visto en cálculo de máximos y
mínimos para encontrar el mínimo de esta
función pero déjenme repetirlo porque si
quiero hacer énfasis en esto yo obtuve
una función que solamente depende de una
variable gracias a que espejo una de
esas variables en ecuación de
restricción muy bien entonces ahora sí
vamos a atacar
primera derivada de s para igualar la 0
como hemos hecho en nuestros problemas
de máximos y mínimos entonces s prima es
igual a 2x más y como derivó a 256 entre
x cuadrada pues esto es lo mismo que 256
y voy a pasar la x cuadrada para arriba
con exponente negativo entonces va a ser
256 que multiplica es menos 2 y
exponente va a ser negativo x sala menos
dos menos uno o sea menos tres muy bien
ya tengo la derivada y si la derivada
que es 2x más más voy a borrar perdón es
menos y cuantos 256 por 2 512 menos 512
x a la menos 3 y con esto ya reduje la
expresión pero ahora sí vamos a recordar
lo que hemos visto en otros vídeos de
máximos y mínimos para ello obtener los
máximos y mínimos de una función es
necesario que igual de la primera
derivada a cero por lo tanto vamos a
hacer 2 x menos 512 x a la menos tres lo
voy a igualar a cero ya que despejará x
entonces
pues se me ocurre pasar el 512 del otro
lado es decir 2x
lo voy a tomar con otro color para
romper la monotonía de colores entonces
de la ecuación de aquí está para no
perdernos que voy a hacer pues voy a
tomar el 2x y lo voy a igualar a 512 x a
la menos 3 es decir estoy pasando el 512
que es el menos 3 del otro lado sumando
muy bien y 502 x a la menos 3 es lo
mismo que 512 entre x kubica entonces yo
tengo 512 entre x kubica puedo pasar del
otro lado la x cúbica y pasaría
multiplicando es decir 2x por equis
kubica es x 4a igual a 512 2x 4a igual a
512 y ahora pues ya despejar de aquí a x
4a es muy fácil
voy a pasar primero el 2 dividiendo y me
va a quedar 502 entre dos que es 256 y
ahora si cuantas la raíz cuarta de 256 o
dicho de otra manera que el número
multiplicado por sí mismo cuatro veces
me da 256 bueno
primero desde cuenta que la raíz
cuadrada de 256 es 16 esto sale de que
16 por 16 256 y bueno de hecho la raíz
cuadrada de 256 es más menos 16 y la
raíz cuadrada de 16 es más menos 4
entonces ahora sí ya tengo que la raíz
cuarta de 256 es 4 más menos 4 pero
bueno si ya sabemos que x vale más menos
4 pues cuánto va a valer y entonces aquí
me quedan dos casos si x vale 4 positivo
y si x vale menos 4 si x vale cuatro
positivo pues lleva al menos 4 porque
menos 16 entre 4 es menos 4 y si x vale
menos 4 pues llevaba a leer a menos 16
entre menos 4 es positivo 4 es el 4
positivo si se dan cuenta al final son
dos números y los números 4 y de otros
menos 4 entonces pues no importa quién
sea xy quien sea y el chiste es que son
dos números y uno de ellos es 4 y en
otros menos 4 y que creen y acabamos
bueno no ha dicho no acabamos lo que
sabemos es que este punto 4 menos 4
es un punto crítico todavía no sabemos
si es máximo o mínimo habrá que probar
si es mínimo y es muy importante que
nosotros hagamos ese ejercicio para ver
que esta función es mínima o máxima lo
que hay que hacer es sacar la segunda
derivada y con la segunda derivada hay
que sustituir los puntos críticos y ver
si el resultado es positivo o si es
negativo acuérdense decir si el
resultado es positivo entonces es un
mínimo y si el resultado es negativo
entonces es un máximo de eso depende la
concavidad de los puntos cercanos a mi
punto crítico entonces si estás s prima
pues que va a ser esa mi prima es decir
la segunda derivada de s con respecto a
x pues bueno va a ser 2 y después menos
por menos es más y 512 por 3 es 1536 no
entonces me queda más 1536 x a la y le
restamos 1 el exponente x a la menos 4
ok bueno de hecho todo estoy aquí usando
un poco más la anotación porque todo
esto tiene que ver con x sería como s de
x y aquí sería s de x y aquí sería s
prima de x y s prima de x bueno ustedes
realmente me entienden no tengo por qué
hacer todo esto pero ahora sí vamos a
sustituir a x por 4 a ver que nos da s
mi prima de 4 es igualdad 2 + 1536 y
aquí es 4 a la menos 4 pero 4 al menos 4
es lo mismo que 1 entre 4 a la 4 que es
lo mismo que 1 entre 256 y ya le es
necesario hacer toda esta operación
porque dos más mil 536 por uno entre 256
es un número positivo que es lo que
queríamos encontrar nosotros nos
importaba si era positivo o negativo el
número y es positivo por lo tanto ya
obtuve la pareja de números x igual a 4
y menos 4 que hacen la expresión x
cuadrada más de cuadrada mínima y que
como se vea una concavidad hacia abajo
pues se ve así esta es una concavidad
hacia abajo
y este es el punto crítico recuerden que
el punto crítico era x igual a 4 y menos
4 esa pareja de números hacía que la
suma de los cuadrados fuera mínima y si
ustedes son escépticos cosa que me daría
mucho gusto podrían intentar encontrar
un par de números que su multiplicación
me dé menos 16 y que tenga una suma de
cuadrados menor a la suma del cuadrados
de 4 y menos 4 de hecho podemos hacerlo
a ver supongamos cuál es el de cuál es
la suma de cuadrados de 4 y menos cuatro
los 4 al cuadrados 16 y menos 4 de
cuadrados 16 16 y 16 son 32 muy bien y a
ver voy a tomar otra pareja de números
supongamos el 1 y el menos 16 1 al
cuadrado más menos 16 elevado al
cuadrado cuánto es esto uno más 256 es
257 y sigue siendo muy grande a
comparación de 32 de hecho ustedes
pueden tomar cualquier pareja de números
por ejemplo el 2 y el menos 8 la que
ustedes se les ocurra y siempre la suma
de sus cuadrados va a ser menor que
mayor que 32 bueno en este vídeo quería
ver tres problemas de optimización y
solamente me dio tiempo de ver uno
entonces para no hacerlo más largo nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo